the aftermath of an attack by Syrian
government forces and their Russian
allies in Eid Lib province the attack
happened hours before a Russian and
Turkish brokered ceasefire was due to
come into effect volunteer white helmet
paramedics were there within minutes to
do what they've done thousands of times
during the war tried to save the lives
of civilians there have been several
airstrikes on two different cities he
went to the sites and while we were
helping people there were more
airstrikes for sure there are people
trapped under the rubble we're still
searching for survivors
omne wrap was one of several villages
hit by Russian and Syrian government
forces in the last 24 hours
this grandfather is burying four out of
his five granddaughters I wasn't here
when the airstrikes happened but I was
told my granddaughter's had been killed
when we came we found their bodies their
parents are in the hospital having
surgery only one three-month-old baby
survived more than 1,300 civilians have
been killed since the government
launched its offensive to retake Italy
province in 2018 this territory is the
last stronghold of groups opposed to
President Bashar al-assad Russia which
supports Assad and Turkey which backs
the rebels announced a ceasefire on
Thursday which has now come into effect
but it was too late
for these children early on the servitor
mafia - what the airstrike led to a
massacre most the victims are children
these are the dead bodies I won the
world feed these children look at the
crimes of Bashar al-assad last August
Russia and Turkey agreed a de-escalation
zone in Italy province but attacks
continued and many here don't believe
this ceasefire will last either
Victoria Gaytan be al-jazeera